Hey guys.
We've got a huge problem in the church today.
A lot of people are listening to preachers who
preach to itching ears, who allow it to happen.
Who listen to motivational messages
that's just puffing up the self life.
But Jesus calls us to deny ourselves.
To pick up our cross and follow Jesus.
I want to read a quote to you
from my book Bold Pursuit.
There's a big problem in the church today.
A problem of lukewarm men who care more about
living for the things of this world than
about living for the God of this world.
You cannot serve Christ with only
your heart or only your mind.
You need both.
In other words, you need to follow
Christ with the right doctrine and devotion.
You need to follow Christ the way
He wants you to follow Him.
Not following Him from the self-life.
You need to deny yourself, pick up your cross
and follow Jesus, if you truly love Him.
I'll see you in the next video.
Bye.